hello to all the YouTube community I'm
Pablo Camacho I was the winner of the
2009 Davos debate and I'm addressing you
now simply because I was asked to say a
few words maybe draw what I can from my
experience at the World Economic Forum
and maybe offer some advice to the new
participants this means that now instead
of interviewing Davos attendees I have
to do something a bit strange and that
is interview myself so what should a
double the weights participant do well
maybe while pondering what to put in
your video you could realize that the
most appealing and sort of striking
feature for the people who are looking
for that one winning entry could be
precisely that which is not in the video
that is that a good response sort of
creates an excess meaning both that it
produces lateral discussions and more
importantly that it points towards a
sort of potential that seems bigger than
the three-minute limit on the video and
that kind of potential that sort of
surpasses the contest itself is really
asking to be set loose on an event such
as the World Economic Forum but this is
actually not what truly matters and this
is sort of just strategy talk what
becomes really valuable is the way in
which you achieve that and that is by
finding within yourself your genuine
concerns about the impending issues
right now because when you do that you
sort of then have everything to say
about it and you can talk forever and
this is what creates that excess that
sort of surpasses the video and the
contest itself and it is through this
perspective where you can see how the
sort of gimmicky strategic context of
video contests actually meets with
honesty authenticity and the
truthfulness that it's so crucial for
this kind of outsider citizen figure in
an event such as the world
McFaul so I hope this can be useful in
any way and I'd like to take this chance
to prematurely congratulate the winner
and all of the participants for taking
their voice under time and transforming
them in public worldwide contributions